foreign
[Music]
taking over the military for sure I
would seek at identity theft
I'm much more afraid for the job loss
portion if it was one it'd probably be
job loss only because I think that's a
possibility in certain industries I
guess I'm probably more worried about
big companies in Ai and the power that
they would have with AI I think as any
shift in society you know whatever
technology has bought and people will
find new avenues for jobs I think it is
just re-skilling that needs to be done
it it takes out a lot of people only
because
like it's starting to do writing now
artists are now like kind of getting
worried about like the art AI things
because it almost feels like they don't
even have a place in like the job Force
anymore and either do Riders because
eventually I feel like it's just it's
all going to take over I just don't
trust the AI is just it's too much it's
too many too much of the computers being
in people's business I don't like it
like I'm pretty sure the AI you know
like is already being applied there's
multiple you know vendors serving the
military doing you know like analyzing
data and things along those lines one
thing I've been thinking deeply about is
you know there is the concept of racial
bias and all these things in the
existing data probably which is being
used to train the AI models hopefully
that can be you know resolved uh like
all like you know people are cognizant
of of that because if you're training a
model to replicate what is existing
which could be like you know different
bias and all these things that already
exists in the world so it wouldn't serve
the purpose hopefully like AI will start
all you know things along those lines
it's growing too quickly it's just it's
I
so fast ly like technology has just been
a thing that I overall that is just like
and not gotten out of control but it's
definitely the pace is quickened like
ever since like the 90s everybody has
talked about that it's insane I think
it'll all get fixed itself over time if
I want to impact my life that much